Цим деревам понад півтора століття. Захисники довкілля
Августин та Войцех намагаються регулярно перевіряти
їхній стан. Мета екологів - вберегти
національний заповідник «Біловезька пуща» від вирубки.
Байдуже - здорові це дерева чи хворі.
Усе це тут - природній лісовий масив. Дуже старий,
віком понад 170 років. Людина не втручалася в його розвиток.
Усе це природні процеси, які тривають вже тисячоліттями.
До цих процесів належить і природнє вимирання дерев.
У такий спосіб звільняється простір для тисяч різновидів живих створінь,
як, приміром, птахи чи комахи.
"Біловезька пуща" перебуває під захистом ЮНЕСКО -
як останній рівнинний праліс Європи.
Цей ліс для мене просто безцінний.
Це єдине місце, де я колись зможу показати своїм дітям,
як виглядає первинний ліс.
Тому я прагну його захистити.
Трохи далі - глибока рілля у лісовому ґрунті.
Це сліди величезних машин, які вирубують дерева.
Тут посеред лісу виникла рукотворна прогалина -
наслідок знищення лісу.
Тут вирубали територію площею понад 100 гектарів.
Ці процеси зайшли вже доволі далеко, як ми бачимо.
Вирубку пралісу обґрунтовують боротьбою з напастю
жуків-короїдів. Квоти на вирубку
за останній рік зросли утричі.
Чіткої концепції, де саме і скільки вирубувати, немає.
У цьому будинку оселилася група захисників лісу.
Впродовж місяців вони організовують вражаючі акції,
аби завадити вирубці дерев.
Частково доходило до сутичок.
Не раз ставалося, що активістів,  які сиділи на машинах,
силоміць знімали звідти.
Це було доволі небезпечно.
Я прив’язала себе до машини.
Один з охоронців заліз до нас вгору
і так десь годину біля нас простояв, розмовляючи з нами.
Ставало дедалі напруженіше, і я боялася, що впаду з машини.
Потім вони перевернули мене на живіт.
Молоді активісти постійно чергуються.
Кожен залишається, скільки може, аби  підтримати протести.
Захист лісу вони вважають своєю місією.
Праліс вимирає. І вже не перший день.
Але після такої масивної вирубки
ліс вже ніколи не зможе відновитися.
Політики не думають про майбутнє.
З точки зору лісників, вирубка дерев здійснюється
виключно з метою захисту лісу.
Інакше короїди знищать лісовий масив,
і цей процес неможливо буде зупинити. Тому, мовляв,
хворі дерева слід знищувати.
Ця територія була небезпечна для людей,
для відвідувачів лісу. Через дерева,
що могли завалитися.
Однак захисники довкілля дотримують кардинально
протилежної думки. Вони намагаються
завадити будь-якому втручанню в природу і критикують,
що столітні дерева бездумно спилюють.
Ці написи вказують, що деревам уже понад сто років.
Згідно з вироком Європейського суду, вирубка та вивезення
цієї деревини нелегальна.
У сусідньому селі думки мешканців розділилися:
одні вважають це доцільним, інші - категорично проти.
Це правильно, що вони вирубують,
бо раніше ми мусили завозити деревину здалеку.
Вирубка краще, ніж ці дерева там згниють.
Навіщо вони вирубують дерева?
Чому знищують наш ліс?
Я тут народилася і я проти вирубки!
Вигляд вирубаних дерев в останньому рівнинному пралісі Європи
шокує екологів. Вони готові на все, аби завадити
подальшій вирубці. Адже цей польський ліс
робить свій внесок
у боротьбу з глобальним потеплінням.